Welcome to Ear Biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk
about life for a long time. I'm Rich.
And I'm Link this week at the round table
of dim lighting.
I gotta talk to you about the trip
that I just got back from,
man, I've been spring breaking it.
And I, again, I've been,
we got nothing to talk about because
you got back and I'm like, well,
I can't ask him about his trip.
Until now.
Now we have everything to talk about.
My trip to Park City, Utah.
Did you have as much fun as
you seem to be projecting?
I did some.
I did. I did some mining.
Crypto.
No, like you actually, I don't know.
That's the first thing I thought
of when I thought of Utah
and I didn't wanna make a Mormon joke.
Oh, was that like, I don't know.
Some sort of precious gem stones, metals.
I think it does happen there.
There's still a lot of
that happening there,
I don't know if you know,
there there's a resurgence of
the gold rush there in Utah.
I totally making that up.
Is that where we mine charcoal?
That wasn't Utah, that was Nevada.
That was Nevada Tonapah,
Nevada for commercial Kings.
So yeah,
I'm gonna give you an update
on my spring break experience
to wet your appetite.
Wet your appetite your own spring break.
I was also here.
I know 'cause you that's what I'm saying.
You have not gone on your spring break.
No, I'm saying while you
were on your spring break,
I was just here by myself.
Yeah. I don't wanna hear about that
unless something catastrophic
happened to the company,
which I assume you
would've already told me
and I was still following along on Slack.
Like I was lurking in
the emails in the Slack,
just to make sure that like
you were holding things down
and it seems that you did. Thank you.
Yeah, I mean, I didn't have,
I had nothing happen
that is worthy of talk,
talking about on Ear Biscuit.
So the runway is clear.
Not that anything,
nothing happened, right?
Stuff did happen. It's just not.
No, I didn't work at all.
Oh, hey.
I mean, I was just on Slack a little bit.
You earned it, you earned it man.
Double up, double up on the spring break.
I did work, but nothing
interesting happened.
'Cause your spring break's coming up.
My spring break.
As of this recording.
My spring break might be a two episode.
Oh yeah.
I don't know.
I love
What's gonna happen.
Fact that like we call
our kids spring break.
I our spring break because we
do make it our spring break.
I mean, we have this luxury of saying,
our schedule from a production standpoint
is pretty much set up
over a year in advance.
And we've learned as soon
as like the schools publish
what their, when are for the kids
that we we're able to block off sometimes.
Yeah. We don't function
like a typical YouTuber.
And every time we interact
with a typical YouTuber about
like being on the show or
doing something together,
we it is a reminder of--
We could have booked it.
What things are like
Nine months ago.
Without a schedule.
It's like you trying to book us. Yeah.
It's like trying to
coordinate with other people
is that's one of the reasons that
we stopped interviewing people on the show
was because, well, they pretty much,
didn't schedule stuff more
than like a couple of weeks
in advance.
And then the like the,
if you try to schedule it before that,
it's like, wow,
I have no clue what I'm doing--
Right.
Two months from now.
I'm like, I know what I'm
doing 12 months from now.
Yeah.
With no exaggeration,
like the things that matter
most that in terms of like
you producing our ongoing content
and then there's like spaces
that are left open for
stuff that we can slide in.
But when it comes to like vacations
and stuff like that,
and you gotta coordinate
with multiple children?
Good gracious.
Right.
But it is kind of a
luxury to be able to say,
Hey, we're gonna kinda run this
year's schedule through
one of the grids being
our kids spring break so that it can be
our own spring breaks, very nice.
It's a very nice thing.
Yeah.
So we went to Park City because,
I let it be more of Lincoln's decision
because when Lilly turned 16 years old,
we had this idea, okay,
16 is gonna be a special year.
We're gonna take a trip
with just the 16 year old.
So Lilly, wherever Lilly wants to go,
we decided to go to London,
she decided to go to London.
I'm sure there's an
Ear Biscuit about that.
Of course, Lincoln turns 16
in the midst of the pandemic.
He also turned 17.
Got nothing.
So we're like, Hey, you know, it's like
your 17 spring break, you get to decide.
And he just said he wanted to go skiing.
And I'm like, oh yeah, okay.
I like this little snow skiing.
You're developing a hobby.
What if he had to said water skiing.
An expensive one.
He was like, oh, to try water skiing,
like how would you have been like,
would you have redirected that?
We would I think--
'Cause your dad's a barefoot water skier.
I would've gone water skiing. Yeah.
It's part of that kinda wants
to go water skiing again.
Have you tried?
Never tried.
The fact now,
Here's the thing.
Barefoot water skiing.
The fact that your dad
has barefoot water skiing
means that you probably have
the correct type of feet.
My foot is nothing like my dad's,
but I think my foot's better.
I have a flat foot.
I think flat foot is perfect foot.
He's got a very achy foot.
He's got a, yeah
I never thought I could,
you know, first of all, I don't,
I've never seen a six foot
seven person barefoot skiing,
but--
With an arch like yours?
I think that you've got
like water skiing feet.
I got skiing feet.
We should do that.
We should bring back the vlogs and link.
I'm definitely--
Link barefoot water skis.
I feel like I could lose a toe or a nose.
It's a dangerous.
It's just no, no, no.
It'll it may.
It'll dag you a little bit,
but you can't get that hurt.
Yeah.
Okay. So I can walk you
through the experiences that
I had with my family and my dogs.
The dogs are actually a
big part of this trip.
And so that was something
that we had to navigate.
So I wanna unpack all that for you,
but something top of
mind, for me, that's not,
I don't think it's related to the trip.
Maybe it will come back to be related.
I wanted to talk first
just to kind of give
more of my anxiety
assessment journey update
at the end of my spiritual
deconstruction episode.
Thanks for the feedback on that.
Thanks for us feedback
on all of our episodes
we use hashtag EarBiscuits.
We look at all those.
I know a lot of you were talking about
how you really enjoyed
getting to know Greg,
the roommate little teaser there,
we're definitely pulling together,
digitizing footage from the archives,
never before seen except when we showed it
for a captive audience in a room,
the first comedy videos that we ever made,
that a lot of them did feature Greg.
I am so--
Digitized those
Excited about this.
You don't understand,
like I had an idea that
you had these tapes,
but I just kind of forgotten,
like what's on these tapes,
all this just random footage of us
in our dorm room,
in our apartment with Greg, with Tim,
all the early videos we made,
all the outtakes from
the early videos we made.
Yes.
So.
And I've only started
scratching the surface.
Right?
Of a...
And just so you know.
Digitizing this stuff.
The only place these
are gonna be available
is the Mythical Society.
And if you're not a member
of the Mythical Society,
now once these things start rolling out,
I just gotta say,
after having watched a few of them.
Yeah.
I'm like, this might be
the most compelling thing
that we've ever made
because it's just
interesting to find something
from like 22, 23 years ago.
That was the very genesis of us.
Yeah.
Starting to try to be funny.
It's the actual start of what we do now
that no one has ever seen,
except for one time beyond
a small group of friends.
So we're planning now how we
wanna roll out these archives
and it needs to be on the Mythical Society
because it's, that's what
the Mythical Society is for
that level of access.
There's also some like special stuff,
some rights and licensing
issues that like,
otherwise we just wouldn't
be able to navigate.
So yeah,
that's a little teaser because
that's also top of mind
for 'cause we're looking at it,
but back to the anxiety stuff.
Yeah. In the spiritual
deconstruction episode at the end,
I talked about how
at the top of the year
with Christie's encouragement
based on conversations
that I was also kind of bouncing off you
and a few other friends.
Deciding to not only get a new therapist,
but also try out anxiety medication.
So I'm on Citraline,
I've gone from 25
milligrams to 50 milligrams
and it's since January
and going through this process,
I've seen it as more of a
I've my level of observation
of my own anxiety
has really gone up.
You know, I 'cause I'm it's,
it feels kinda like an experiment,
like, okay, now I'm
taking these pills that,
I'm open to it.
I just, and you know,
people close to me have
had really good experiences
and then it's had a positive
impact on their life.
So it's, I haven't had a
stigma associated with it.
I just never made the connection
that I personally needed it.
But then I kind of got
over that hump that, yeah,
I think I could benefit from this.
I just need to observe
what impact it's having
just to see if this is
a good choice for me.
And then also if it is,
and I do believe that it is
like I've experienced positive benefits.
What now is the like right dose?
How do I dial that in?
Because even like
yesterday and this morning,
especially this morning,
like I realized, I was like, man,
I am so anxious.
I and I do think I am more in tune with
how I'm feeling like my
therapist is helping me
like observe more of
the symptoms of anxiety
and my body like, oh, I
feel a little nauseous.
I feel a little tight.
Yesterday by the end of the day I realized
and when I got home,
I was like, you know what?
I'm just, today was a tough day.
I was just really angry.
And it was like, and the
frustrating thing is that like,
I don't know why,
like I start searching for
the thing that made me angry
and feel frustrated.
And it's like, I can't point to one thing.
It's like, nobody did anything to me.
And then today it wasn't.
And so it was one of those things
where it was like,
I'm kind of ready for this date in,
I'm gonna go to bed at nine o'clock,
which is only 20 minutes
earlier than when my--
Right, about say, that's
not too much of a stretch.
You are right.
And then today--
Did your music start playing?
There was, yeah,
it starts playing.
But then today it was like,
I just woke up anxious,
just like very on edge,
very nervous, not angry
anymore, not frustrated,
but I was just trying to figure out
what it was,
but then also try to
employ some techniques
that I'm learning to deal with it.
Whether I know the answer or not.
So like some brief breathing
techniques of like slow
breathing in like straw
breathing, where you,
you breathe in slowly,
but then you breathe out
as if you're breathing to,
through a straw so that your out breath
is like longer than your end breath.
'Cause a signal to your
body that you can calm down.
But yeah, it's on one hand observing,
this is kind of a good data point
that like I'm on the right track.
That like all the things
that I'm doing are necessary
for me.
It's because this is a reminder, oh,
I've got this flare up of anxiety.
Then I start to like, try
to figure out what it is.
It's like, well, I don't
know exactly what I don't,
I don't feel like I
have some amazing thing
that I wanna bring to this episode.
And you know, this is my episode, right?
I'm supposed to be, you expect me, like,
you're not preparing anything.
Am not prepared at all.
This is my trip.
I'm supposed to be
bringing something to this.
So that the first thing
I point to is like, okay,
I get in my own head about,
well, I don't feel prepared.
Like this is one thing that
really sets off anxiety for me
is just not feeling like I've got this.
Like you don't have this.
And that's kind of a theme.
I think for me that I
realize over over many years,
maybe over my entire life,
it's like, okay, yeah, this is a,
this is a legitimate signal
and symptom of anxiety
that like, I just never labeled.
So there's that.
And then I'm like when we leave here,
we're gonna go and meet
up with Julian Smith.
Well, that's another teaser.
I'm full of teaser today.
We reconnected with our over and Julian.
I don't know if I,
I guess he's okay me teasing this,
but like we're shooting
something with him.
It's his control, whether
it, it sees the light of day,
but I think I found myself
being very keyed up about that.
And I don't know why
it's like this should be something that's,
it's fun to reconnect.
But I feel like, I mean,
I feel like it's very natural.
Okay.
Like I don't know.
I mean, I feel like the way
that you're talking to about it
is I'm anxious about these things.
And if I was normal,
I wouldn't be anxious about it.
Like, I don't have a
diagnosable anxiety disorder,
but I get anxious about stuff all the time
that we're about to do in the same way.
And it I'll be like, oh, and, and then,
and I'll be driving home and I'll be like,
what is it what's going,
why am I feeling this way?
And then I'll like, try to
find, I'll try to find it.
I try to get to the root of and like, oh,
we're doing that thing.
And yeah, I don't feel prepared for it.
And I bet you I'll feel
better when it's over.
And then if I'm right, I will.
And then I actually start
fantasizing about it
being something that should be fun,
being done and being over and being like,
and then I'm gonna get home
and I'm gonna eat dinner
and I'm gonna watch TV.
And that won't be stressful.
Yeah.
So, I mean, I guess so I'm not,
I'm not dismissing your anxiety.
I'm just saying like it--
No, this exactly.
It doesn't make you weird.
I think it makes you normal.
Yeah. I think this is
exactly what I'm trying
to figure out because
I've been on completely
on that side of on that perspective
on the outside of,
I'll put it in the extreme
and anxiety diagnosis
and saying for myself, it's like, yeah,
I get stressed out.
Stress is a natural response
to having to step up.
And when pressure hits you,
stress is a good thing
because it gets you ready.
It's human.
Yeah.
It's not just a problem.
Something that should be
therapized or anesthetized away
or however you wanna say it, away.
So I'm like, yeah, of
course I get stressed out,
but then it's like, okay.
It gets to a level where
you have heart palpitations
sometimes, you know, they'll come and go.
But like, okay, that
may be, that may have a,
an impact on my health
long term, you know?
Yeah.
And, but yeah, that's how I've kind of,
I've put it in this box of like,
well, what you've just said,
and now I've kind of switched
over to the other side.
It's like, what if, yeah.
What is normal and what is
more of disordered level
of dealing with anxiety?
Well, I think my sort
of slightly informed,
but most nonprofessional opinion
or perspective on the,
like an anxiety disorder is
when you have an anxiety disorder,
a lot of times it will be,
there's a baseline of anxiety.
And then you'll kind of begin filling it
with things that you
could be anxious about.
So it's almost like the anxiety starts
and then the event or the
circumstances fill it versus
a more normal response
to is an event makes
you become anxious about something.
Now, obviously if you
become anxious about it
to a extreme degree
that like affects your functioning
and your health and that's extreme,
but it's almost like
people, people who are,
you know, deal with depression,
they wake up in the morning
and they feel depressed.
Not because they had a bad day or not,
because they're anticipating
having a bad day,
but there's something in the
chemical makeup of their brain
that just be giving them the blues,
giving them a feeling of depression.
And then you start trying
to connect it to like,
is it for this? Or is it that?
Ooh, no, it might just be a brain thing
and there could be treatment for that.
So do you, do, what your question is...
What you're describing is
a bucket of that I need to,
that I could fill with something to always
have an object of my anxiety.
'Cause you feel like your baseline anxiety
has changed after being on this
medication for three months.
'Cause at this point it
should have kicked in, right?
Yeah. Yeah.
It has, but I think what's
happened is, you know,
I could add other things to the list.
It's like, okay Christy gave me a report
about a conversation she had with my mom
about Louis having another stroke.
And then,
I got a friend that I want
to have a conversation with
that the friend's not is
going through something
that like, I haven't been able
to have that conversation.
So there's like this,
some energy going out in that direction.
And so there's this
cumulative effect of, okay,
that then I wake up
and I just feel like in a knot, you know?
And so it's, and honestly,
I kind of thought
because I've been experiencing some,
the benefits of the medication
and the therapy everything
that at it was,
it is a bit discouraging
to find that like, okay,
now that these things have piled on,
it kind of feels like I'm back where I was
at least yesterday and today.
So it's then you start to think about,
well, does that mean,
should I consider up in the medication?
I'm still in that zone where
I'm trying to dial that in.
I think what I'm concluding,
even in this conversation
is that like, okay,
let me see if this wave passes,
if the baseline is still,
and I'll also talk to my doctor.
And my therapist.
Yeah, right. Your doctor can help you.
So in terms of hashtag Ear Biscuits, I,
you don't have to give
me advice on that front.
Oh don't worry, they will.
But yeah, I'll also,
I have a follow up schedule with my doctor
and I'm talking to my therapist tonight,
but I'm just kind of sharing just,
the what's at work in assessing
my anxiety and kind of getting comfortable
with the fact that like,
I am treating it and
I am talking about it.
Yeah.
And I'm not talking about
getting comfortable with
talking about it publicly,
just wrapping my mind around,
in all conversations that like,
Hey this is a part of
what I'm dealing with.
And I'm coming to grips with it.
And I'm still developing a game plan.
And I'm just observing
and that I'm observing things more closely
than I never did.
So it's like the more things that come up,
it's like, oh yeah,
that's been something
that's been true of me
for my entire life.
Now I'm seeing it
through a different lens,
of treatment and it is very helpful.
And it's, so I do feel very
positive about it overall.
All it's just the past few days,
it's been more of a dip.
And we are getting back into
a more stressful schedule.
I was thinking about this other night,
there were there there's
like two weeks in a row
where almost every night
I had some commitment.
Yeah. Now some of it was like fun stuff.
Like, oh we're going to a concert
or we've got our date night scheduled,
but other nights there were
like some social engagement
or, and I was just like,
man, this is...
The world opening back up is absolutely...
So there's that.
A factor
So there's a little,
there's less of this little
respite in the evening.
It's like getting home
at 10:30, 11, 11:30.
It's a lifestyle shift.
And realizing that this is
what my life used to be like.
And the other thing is,
we've always had a lot going on,
but there's a lot of things getting
to a stage where they're taking more time.
I mean...
Or just feeling like what,
with all these designers in the fire,
which one's gonna catch the
oven admit when I'm not looking.
Yeah, yeah.
So, I mean, I've definitely
been feeling that.
I mean, that's where I
talk to my therapist about
last week is just like,
oh God, I'm beginning to feel like the,
the pressure is increasing.
And it's been,
as difficult as the pandemic
was in many, many other ways,
the one positive thing about it
was there's a little,
it seemed like there was
a little pressure in,
in some ways there's,
there was less demands on our time
and that's kind of reversing.
So I'm, I mean, I'm not
surprised that you're,
that you're feeling,
that you're feeling a little bit of a,
that the anxiety is like.
Getting a little prickly.
You know what I think I need a little bit,
I think I need a vacation.
I think I need a spring break.
Yeah. That is interesting thing.
'Cause you just got
back from the vacation.
I do think that's also a factor is
like yesterday was my first day back.
So it's--
Vacations tend to make anxious,
because yep.
You're like, well,
what did I fall behind on?
I definitely felt, felt some of that.
So yeah, I think,
I'm gonna be in observation mode at least
for another week coming out of this.
And, but before I'm like
making any decisions
about changing my approach,
'cause I do feel very good
and still mostly excited
about and confirmed about
being on the right tracks
for what I'm doing here.
But yeah, I wouldn't,
I'd love to go back to Park City.
Let's switch to that.
I, but first let's get
some promo in for our
Oh boy.
Our boy Trevor's Podcast.
Trevor talks too much
Mythical Kitchen, Trevor.
He's a, you know, he's really
good at making pastries.
You know that like he's.
Good at making pastries.
He's good at making conversations.
He's, he's good at making a lot of things,
but he's like got some like special high,
high dollar training in
that pastry area I think.
We're trying to be building up.
He doesn't do that on the podcast.
That's I'm trying to build up the podcast.
But if you like the idea
of somebody being really
good at pastries and also really good at--
Talking to somebody.
Yeah, yeah.
I mean the,
the TLC that goes into
a pastry perfect pastry
is very similar to the TLC that goes
into a perfect episode of a podcast.
Okay.
You know, you gotta,
you gotta fold that
croissant there's there,
you have many layers.
He brings in guests
that, for me that it's,
it's bringing a fresh
perspective into my world.
Yeah.
Through Trevor's perspective, Mxmtoon.
She's an artist that I, when
we pulled up her music video,
it's like, oh, she's
yeah, she's got something.
I like her style.
So listen to that conversation,
knowing you banks is a gamer, check out,
check out that one.
And the, to libe twins
are coming on very soon.
If not already. Yeah.
He's getting the mix, man.
He's getting the mix.
Trevor toss too much.
It's a fun, listen, learn something.
If you're into these people
that he's having on there.
Great. And if you're not,
you should expand your world.
Oh yeah. If you're an oldie like us
and you want, feel it little bit less.
Come out and say, yeah, of course.
We've been to Park City, a number of times
Park City's known for being the venue
for the Sundance Film Festival
towards the top of every year.
And so we found ourselves at
the Sundance Film Festival
in all like tertiary capacities.
We were there with, we,
we were making videos.
Cadillac.
With Cadillac.
We were like interviewing celebrities.
About Cadillacs.
You can go back and on
the rent Link channel,
check that out.
We went, we were guests of
YouTube a couple of times.
Like they, they had like,
A lounge.
Yeah.
So we did some Q and A's and stuff like
that and saw a few documentaries
when we were there.
But, and then we would like
maybe ski for a few hours.
And then sometimes we
would see our friend Eric
who, our high school friend
who was one of the guitarists
and the Wax Paper Dogz.
So Eric's lived there
for like 20 years now.
He's like worked in and around the,
the mountain resorts doing
like high up technology stuff.
But he started as, as a snow maker.
So yeah, I got to reconnect with Eric,
got to hang out with him.
So I'm like, he was, you know, he,
he definitely wanted to like
say, oh, you should do this.
You should go here. He was, he was like a,
he was like a Sherpa.
Oh, he was like ski patrol
at some point, I think right?
In the early days.
He just told me he was a snow maker.
And then he went into
like the IT department.
But he knows, he knows all the,
he knows the mountains.
The thing that I remember and I,
I didn't bring it up this time
'cause I just didn't want to
rehash the story with him again.
But I'll do it here.
When we went to Sundance that one time
and we went, we were,
we had some drinks and I'm
gonna say a combination
of the altitude and not being acclimated
to that and having a few too many drinks
for that particular environment.
I don't remember this.
I woke up the next morning.
We're like, before we
leave town, we got Eric.
We gotta meet you.
We're gonna meet you for breakfast.
And he like, so we met up
at this breakfast place
and I have not been
hungover often in my life.
Okay.
There was the one time in high school
that I told the story.
And then there was, I mean,
there's sometimes you like
wake up with a headache,
but like, like what
I've never woken up and
before my eyes are open,
the, I could tell that
the room is spinning.
Except like a couple of times,
like I, once you experience that once
it takes me like 10, 15
years before I forget,
apparently that I never
wanna feel that again.
And I think the time and
worked out just right
that like, oh my gosh,
I woke up the room was spinning.
Then I opened my eyes.
I was like, yep. I don't,
am I gonna be able to get outta bed?
It was bad. And I don't remember this.
Yes you do because I
was wearing sunglasses
and we were like,
I was like, dude, I don't feel good.
And we got a, like an Uber
to the breakfast place
to meet Eric.
And I didn't tell Eric
that I felt bad.
I just wore my sunglasses the whole time.
It was very bright.
And we were like wearing these heavy coats
'cause it was like snowy outside.
And then we go inside
and it's like baking hot.
And the sun is baking through the window
and shining right in my eyes, which-
Well at least you got sunglasses on.
At least gave me a reason
to wear the sunglasses.
And-
You guys were also at Sundance,
it makes you look like you're somebody
if you got sun glasses inside.
I was sweating.
Like doing that, like hangover sweat.
And like we're talking to Eric
and we're like catching up.
And I was trying to like convey
that I was so happy to see him,
'cause it had been a while.
And then I just let the two
of you do most of the talking
while I just sat there and like
I was looking at the menu,
and I remember that the
menu made me nauseous.
And then Eric ordered one
of those Egg Benedict things
where it's like,
you poked the egg and it oozes out like-
Yeah, like a properly made Eggs Benedict.
Like something that like
an EMT should be like
working on at the back of an ambulance.
Oh my gosh, It's like,
or like an eye surgeon or something.
Yeah. You've just described the
properly made eggs Benedict.
And I remember looking
at that and I was like,
"I need to go to the restroom."
And I went to the bathroom.
You remember this?
I'm kind of...
it's beginning to piece together.
And I was,
I was about to vomit at the table,
and then I'm like
shimming to the bathroom,
and I got to the bathroom,
and I started,
when I saw the toilet, I just
started vomiting, you know?
Before I got to the toilet.
Why didn't you feel
like you could tell him
that you were hungover?
I don't know.
Because I was embarrassed.
It's so dumb.
I think it was in that weird
zone where it was like,
it might have been a little
holier than thou thing.
I don't think so though.
There's no way that could have been it.
Was that the Cadillac year?
Yes. I think it-
That might have been it,
Might have been, if it was back then.
That might have been it.
The first time we went to Sundance.
Yeah, because that was like.
2008, 2009.
Pre deconstruction, Pre deconstruction.
And we were like trying to be these like,
we wanted to keep up appearances.
You can't let 'em know you're hungover,
because God will be upset with you.
I just think I was embarrassed.
I don't know how spiritual it was but,
I had a lot of cleaning
up to do in the bathroom.
Oh God.
Because, you know,
I'm like taking all the
paper towels and like
trying to mop up the-
So you missed the toilet?
Yeah man, I missed the floor.
I like hit the wall a little bit.
Went out the window?
Hit the wall.
It's like you ever been in
the bathroom and you're like,
who exploded?
How do you explode everywhere?
Well, I understand.
And I don't,
I still don't know the
answer to that for poop,
'cause I've seen that.
I understand the vomit,
but I don't understand
the diarrhea explosion
in a bathroom man, Like,
Like-
I'm so curious,
I would be willing to be
there to see it happen.
Like it's a nastiest thing,
but I'm just so curious.
I'm like, what position were they in?
So every time I get together, I mean,
like I mopped everything up.
'Cause I was not gonna leave
that for the employees.
But it took me a long
time to come back out.
And when I came back
out, I think it was like,
"Guys, I'm just, I've had a,
I've had a rough time in the restroom,
and I'm still having
a rough time out here.
I'm glad you're finished with your,
your bursted eyeball egg."
You're poached eggs.
So that's what I think about every time I,
I go back to Park City and
especially when we see Eric but-
Oh, you have like a Pavlovian
vomit response to Eric?
No, it's no, no, it's not that bad.
Good, good, good.
The main thing, I booked at Airbnb and
I was like,
every time since I think
since we first got Jade,
I was like, we're gonna take this dog.
We're gonna fly with this dog.
I've seen people do it.
We're gonna take Jade home with us.
I love Jade, she's a member of the family.
I want her to be with me.
But we never did it.
Like it's, you know, you
go, you gets down to it.
And you're always like,
It's not worth it.
It's probably, tough on Jade.
It's like, she likes the,
the kennel we take her to.
it's called a freaking
pet resort, you know?
They sleep on beds.
It's like, they got like webcams.
You can see 'em at all times.
Yeah. It's pretty nice.
It's great.
Barbara loves it.
It's ridiculous.
And Barbara's there.
Usually at the same time.
So we always talked ourselves out of it.
But I was like,
"Christy, now that you're
so attached to Jasper,"
or at least that's what I was thinking.
Now that she's so attached to Jasper.
I'm like, this is a, this is,
we're gonna do it this time.
Like we've taken road trips.
Like when we went to Sedona,
we took the cats, the dog and the cat,
right when we got the
cat, which was crazy.
So it's not that we haven't
gone on trips with the dogs.
Like if we do that on like
a beach trip or something.
But they've never flown with us.
So I'm like Park City. This
is a very short flight.
It's like around an hour.
It's like, this is a good test.
And plus me, Lincoln and
Lando are gonna be skiing.
Christy, You're gonna
be bad at the Airbnb,
just chilling out,
doing what you wanna do.
This is what she...
She was looking forward to that.
But I was like,
"Don't you want your
little furries with you?
Your animals don't you want your dogies?"
And I was like, let's do this.
So she said yes.
And it was really because
she's so attached to Jasper like,
oh my gosh, it's like,
like a little baby to her.
He does better at the,
the kennel now though, right?
I mean like,
'Cause I picked him and J up.
Right, and posted on your Instagram.
I mean, and he did like have like a-
He's very clingy, but he's gotten better.
Like he had, he had separation anxiety.
He didn't seem super traumatized
when I picked him up.
Yeah, he's lived with us for a year now.
And he is so he's,
he's doing so much better on that front.
So that really wasn't a factor.
So, I mean, with Delta at least,
you gotta go to a special
counter, when you get there.
And yet we had the,
like the little carriers
that are like Delta approved.
So like, okay, if I buy this one,
I know it will fit under
the seat in front of me and,
'cause the last thing I
wanted to be turned away
'cause my carrier was too big.
So we got out all that squared away.
We even the weeks leading
up to it, I was like,
all right, Christy,
we're gonna put the dogs in the kennel
and we're gonna walk 'em around.
I think I'm gonna take 'em downtown,
take 'em into town, not downtown LA,
but like take 'em into town,
like around the shops area and just like
carry 'em in the carrier.
Both of them?
Both of 'em.
Just to like get 'em acclimated to being
carried in a carrier.
Right.
And because she laughed in my face,
just like you did just now,
I didn't do that,
but I didn't think it was that weird,
to carry two dogs in a carrier.
I think you gotta get 'em used to it.
In like a bustling little shopping area.
Yeah, I was just like a
man carrying two dogs.
I mean, that guy's going somewhere.
Typically you would walk
your dog in a shopping area.
Not carry them in a carrier.
Head in or head out?
I didn't do it,
but around the house I would do it
and I'd put their head in, yeah.
And then we got there,
and you gotta go to a special counter,
'cause you gotta pay a fee for this,
it's like $150 per dog, one way.
That's another passenger man.
It's actually a good deal.
Man, it's not real.
It's not another seat.
Yeah, but it's,
I mean people's dogs create
issues for other people.
You can't, you had to
discourage it a little bit.
You gotta discourage it a little bit.
You gotta put in a speed bump.
People are willing to pay
like for us, $600 round trip.
You know every once in a while
that dog's gonna take a
crap inside the kennel,
people are gonna smell it
and you gotta discourage it.
You gotta discourage it.
You're right.
So we get there to the
curbside and I ask the guy,
I was like,
we have dogs, we've
never traveled with dogs.
I think we have to go to special county.
He's like, "Follow me.
So he takes us around,
a decent size line.
And then he like, he skips the line,
goes and talks to one of the agents,
whispers and then points at us,
and like stands us kind of to the side
in front of the line.
This is checking in?
Checking in.
And then the guy leaves and I'm like,
I gave him a tip
because the dude just like
escorted us to skip the entire line.
I was a little self-conscious about that.
I'm really nervous
about having these dogs,
and then Jasper from
within the crate thingy,
the carrier sees another dog,
and we're standing in front of everybody,
That's trouble.
And he barks twice, two barks.
Really?
Two barks.
Just two?
Just two.
And then all of a sudden, I
see from a long ways down,
there's like one, two,
three, four, five, six,
seven agents behind,
and then way down there,
this woman just starts
huffing and puffing,
down behind everybody.
Maybe she's a manager of some sort,
comes all the way around,
and goes up to Christie,
'cause Christie was
holding Jasper's carrier.
He says, "Ma'am,
if you don't get your
dog to start barking,
you're gonna have to
take him out of here."
I'm like what?
I'm like he barked twice, just two barks.
And I'm like, what?
This is an employee?
Employee, I'm like, man, this is intense.
I'm about to shell out the dough, come on.
And you were thinking Jasper,
did bark twice.
He'd get a lot worse than this.
And this was the main
thing I was worried about.
So then I like, I'm like crap.
I was like, okay, we will,
we'll do what we can thinking,
I don't know what we're gonna do.
But then I took off my jacket,
and I just draped it over the whole thing
where he couldn't see anything.
Alligator mode.
Yeah.
And I thought he was,
I thought that would just
make him freak out more.
But it actually didn't, it worked.
I don't know.
I would not have predicted
it would've worked or,
or that I would done that to start with.
But yeah, that definitely worked.
And then we take him through security.
I'm having to google like
all this stuff, like,
you put the dog through the thing,
if you do, does it fry him?
You don't wanna put him-
What does it smell like.
when you cook a dog in a-
Well, it wouldn't cook him,
but the effects would show up later.
Delayed, delayed.
It's an x-ray.
Yeah.
I mean, dogs get X-rayed all the time.
Not at that level.
Yeah.
I took the dog out of the carrier,
held Jade in my arms and
Jasper and Chrissy's arms,
and we walk 'em through
and then put 'em back in the carrier.
By that point,
They do a cavity search
of either of the dogs?
No.
Good.
Not of me either. Okay.
It's a little disappointing,
I'm still waiting for that.
Well, you gotta store
something up your butt hole.
They ended up doing
really well on the flight.
The vet had given Christie
a sedative for the dogs,
which-
The vet given Christie a sedative.
So she was okay.
Christy has her own version of a sedative,
'cause she has,
a pronounced fear of flying.
Did the dogs help create
a distraction for her
that made her less focused on her own-
Not on the first flight because
we were so keyed up about
what's, everything was new
and we were worried about
all of the logistics that
I'm telling you about.
So it was like, we were pretty
on edge for that reason.
but we get him on the plane,
We put him underneath the seat in front,
and then they're,
they did great.
By the time we got off the plane,
we were like,
unzip in the top and walking
down the baggage clinging.
Like their heads are sticking out,
and it's like,
all of a sudden this is feeling,
we're feeling like those people.
So they didn't bark at all on the plane?
They did not bark at all on the plane.
After we took off, I asked
the woman next to me.
Well I'll tell that story in a second.
After we took off,
they eventually got up
and got in our laps.
I mean they're little cat dogs.
They just want to be in our laps.
And once they're in our laps,
they're like they just sleep.
Jasper looked out the window a little bit,
but like, not a peep out of 'em.
They did...
They were like docile.
The sedative had an effect on Jasper.
He was really sleepy,
but it really didn't
have an effect on Jake.
She didn't,
she didn't sleep any.
And I was also concerned
about them using the bathroom,
but like,
we made sure they went right
before we left the house,
and then they didn't...
There's like pet pee and poop areas
designated in airport terminals.
Oh, but not on the plane.
No, not on the plane.
In the terminals,
but we didn't want to take 'em in there
and they were fine.
They didn't have to use
the bathroom until we got
to where we were going.
But what about,
Short flight though.
A cross country flight?
'Cause I'm thinking about
doing this with Barbara.
You have to look into it.
I think cross country
flight, you can do it
I've seen dogs.
But if you're flying to Hawaii,
I think I read that you
have to put the dogs,
you have to check the dogs,
which is not something I would want to do.
They have to go in the luggage thing?
I don't know exactly where they go.
They can't go in the luggage thing.
It's that gets too cold.
It's not pressure regulated.
They go, they,
I don't know exactly where they go.
I don't wanna find out.
And I don't wanna put my dogs in there.
I just wouldn't take 'em.
There's the emotional support route,
which I'll get to that in a second.
But,
I mean, pulling out the...
No one ever wanted to pull out the dogs
on the return flight.
I turned to the woman next to me,
when we first sat down
because I was like,
"How are you with dogs?"
'Cause you don't want
to freak somebody out.
Which is what I think that
the manager who is freaking, out was like,
"You gotta do something
about your dog barking."
because some people freak out.
Some people are afraid of dogs.
And it's like, well you gotta,
the people take precedent over the dogs.
If you can't control your dog,
then hey you-
You're gonna lose customers.
You, gonna lose customers.
So I was trying to be
sensitive to this passenger
who was sitting next to me on the flight.
She was like, "Oh I love dogs."
So then we pulled out our
dogs a little bit later
and she was happy.
And then she pulls out her phone
and she shows us a picture of her dog.
But it's a selfie of her with her dog.
I'm like, "Oh you got a cute dog."
You are a dog person.
When I looked at the picture,
it was a bit strange because,
the woman, the picture she showed me it,
she had applied that
face, filter to her face,
and I just don't get it.
Like a face tune.
Yeah. Like a face tune where it's like,
it makes your face like,
it looks like really smooth.
Like you have on makeup.
Right.
I mean she had on some
makeup, in real life
and like I'm sitting right next to her,
but it's like, that is not,
I can tell it's you, but it's not you.
It's like the emoji
version of you. It's like,
this is obviously a fake you.
You've put a filter on yourself.
It just, I don't know.
The whole thing is just strange to me.
Yeah, a lot of people do it.
Of course I see all the people
on TikTok that are like,
"This is not my face."
Yeah, but they're at least
drawing attention to it.
Yeah, at least they're
But it gets stranger,
when a stranger is
showing you this picture.
Usually you see this
person like on Facebook.
Right, and there's-
Not on a plane showing you the picture.
And the phone's not
right next to their face.
Right, that's the issue.
What made it even weirder was again,
the whole point is that the
dog's in the selfie too,
and the face filter was
applied to the dog too.
Did you know that could happen?
The dog's face was like,
Super smooth?
Altered,
that the only thing I can-
like a puppy?
No the only thing I could
really tell was that,
the left eye of the dog,
it was like a Chihuahua.
The left eye of this Chihuahua,
was like darkened and bigger.
It was like the shadow on the
left side of the dog's face
was interpreted by the filter
as part of the dog's eye.
So the left eye of the dog
was like twice as wide,
as the right eye of the dog.
And this woman thought that was cute?
I think, I don't know
why she showed me that.
Are you Sure It just wasn't
a big-eyed Chihuahua?
Well, I didn't wanna ask at that point,
because then I'd be like,
"And is that what your
face normally looks like?"
'Cause I think that's a special breed.
I think I saw that one.
Big left-eyed Chihuahua.
Yeah, yeah.
That's specific, yeah.
It's a little asymmetrical.
The face smoothing
didn't know what to do
with that dog's eye.
You think she hasn't looked at the dog?
She's showing you picture of her dog.
Yeah.
I just think that people
are kind of blind to like
how strange the filter, like,
it's like you can't see how obvious it is.
But if you're looking at your...
I'm gonna find a picture of my dog
to show to strangers when they ask,
"Oh, that's a cute one."
You're looking at the dog, this is weird.
It's so weird.
But to me-
I think maybe you were actually
the victim of an internet prank video
and you didn't respond.
No, she was being sincere.
It was, to me, it just highlights the,
the problem, like the,
just how these face filters
have just fooled people.
Like,
Well, they haven't fooled many people.
No, but the people who use them
think they're fooling people.
And I'm not talking about
the ones that are like,
"This is not my face."
Some of them are real crazy.
That it's amazing how much
with nothing to compare it to
you're like, oh, that
person's gone through like a,
makeup makeover.
It's like very extreme and modelish.
But it is realistic, like,
the technology's getting amazing.
But the one that people normally use,
like for the past year or two,
on I guess, Facebook
or whatever, Instagram,
it's very obvious that
you're applying this filter,
to everybody except the person
who's applying the filter.
Yeah, I think you lose perspective on it.
You lose perspective on it.
And it's a problem.
It's I mean-
What are you gonna do about it?
I think it's gonna become my thing,
Like a crusade against face filters.
I mean, obviously it's like,
it just seems dysfunctional, right?
Yeah, well, you know, it is a-
And if you fool to the point
where you're putting a dog in it.
I wonder if the idea is, okay,
so obviously we all do some sort of
altering of our face or whatever.
Like when we shoot things on video, we,
just, so we're not a
couple of shining boys.
We put some make-up on,
I'll put in some eyedrops
because I have perpetually
bloodshot eyes and everyone's
like, he's always high.
And I'm like, no,
I just have bloodshot
eyes and I have to put in.
So I do some artificial things to my face,
to make myself more presentable, right?
Yeah, yeah.
You're saying you're on a
slippery slope to face filter?
No I'm saying and culturally,
Yeah.
And traditionally women are more
apt to do more things to
their face, with makeup
than men are.
That's changing a little bit,
but like that is sort of,
you know, the norm in the past.
And then it's,
and you know when somebody's
got makeup on, like,
so if somebody shows up
and they've got makeup on,
that like it's decorative in some way,
it's like,
"Oh, there's a different color
over this person's eyes."
We've kind of accepted that.
Maybe the people who are
doing face filters are like,
I'm not trying to fool you.
I know that it's obvious
that I have a face filter,
but this is the face
that I want to show you.
This is the face of my little
dog, that I wanna show you.
I want the big eye thing,
'cause I think that's cute.
It's a leap from wearing
makeup to face filters.
I agree.
Actually, I don't believe
that's what's happening.
I think what's happening
is, people lose perspective.
I think, what you're doing here
and I really appreciate it,
it's because we don't have
a strong point of view.
I'm just trying to figure it out, is that,
we know we're gonna get
some sort of comment that has,
it presents a different perspective.
That's that might have
to lead to an apology.
That's the world we live
in on our podcast in on the
internet. Right?
I don't wanna offend anybody
who uses a face filter,
but at the same time I, and
so when I say something like,
is this a sign of dysfunction?
It's like, okay,
is that a line that I can't
cross conversationally because
someone's gonna come out of
the woodwork and say, well,
have you thought about it
this way? And it's like, okay.
Yeah. Obviously people have a
right to put on a face filter.
I just don't understand it.
And I'm not saying it's
dysfunction, I'm asking a question.
Now I'm being so defensive.
Well, I mean, what I
see when I see it, so,
I don't get it though.
And, you know, it happens.
It's like, and again,
I don't go on Facebook,
and my wife doesn't go on Facebook,
because, you know, in many ways,
Well, there's Instagram too though?
Yeah, I know, but I feel like,
Facebook is the place where you just,
I feel like it's more prominent
there because Facebook
and the people who use Facebook maybe,
instead of Instagram, right?
Which is a certain genre,
or a certain sort of generation, even.
I think that-
I think people on Facebook are more likely
to not realize that it's obvious
they're using a face filter.
People who use Facebook as
their primary social media
are less technically savvy
than people who don't,
that's a generalization that
I'm willing to make, right?
You made it.
And I think that it's just like,
it's like when your mom goes on Facebook,
and sends a message to you,
like "Call me immediately."
But she makes it her like
status update, you know,
like that kind of stuff
happens all the time.
"Brian call me immediately."
And it's just like,
her best friend has liked it.
"Yes Brian do that."
That mom is,
or dad, I'm not trying to say it's women.
I'm saying moms and dads,
and parents of all kinds,
are probably more likely to
use a face filter in a way that
they did not.
They lost perspective at
some place along the way.
And so when I see it, I don't-
'Cause it's different than
getting plastic surgery.
You're talking about makeup,
but then you got okay,
if you got lip amplification
or I don't know,
you've got the high, you've
got the cheek implants,
whatever you got, I don't know.
I don't care. It's fine you know, it's,
I do feel like this is
different because it's like,
I don't know.
It's a different thing.
I like if I couldn't grow a beard,
I would consider getting a chin implant.
But you wouldn't consider-
I'm just honest being honest with you.
Applying a beard filter
to all of your pictures.
No, but I grow a beard as a filter.
What?
My beard is a filter.
I mean, it's natural, It grows naturally,
so I guess cutting it would
be going against nature,
but I'm just saying that like-
But you wouldn't walk around.
Well, I mean like a beard toupée,
does that exist by the way?
I'm sure, if it can be conceptualized,
it can be invented and as-
Yeah, sure, people have
beard toupées, beardpees.
I'm saying, I agree with you.
When I see somebody
who's done a face filter,
I think this person has identity issues.
That's what I think that's
my knee jerk reaction.
But then I, when I've turned
that lens back on myself,
I'm like, well, you
identity issues as well.
Sure.
But you're just being
a little bit more savvy
in the way that you're addressing them.
I,
I mean, you might have more,
more self consciousness
than someone who's willing
to use a face filter.
It's like, "Hey, I wanna
share this picture,
but I don't wanna,
I don't wanna put on
makeup to take a picture.
I'm just gonna put this face filter on,
and then I'm gonna post that picture.
It's like, so what, who cares?
To me it comes down to
do you know that people
know it's a face filter?
It's like, do you know that people know?
Are you okay with people knowing
that this is a face filter?
Are you okay with people
knowing you were wearing makeup?
Are you okay?
I think most people who
use it don know that-
That you have plastic surgery.
I think it's maybe that's
what I'm addressing.
Well, I saw one where it was the whole,
they had done the whole family.
Because the thing that happened,
sometimes is, was.
Was there a dog in the
photo, cause it'll get wonky.
The thing is sometimes is one
person who is the person's
account It is,
they've done the face tune
filter to just themselves.
So let's just say it's a
person in the family and,
and the other, the spouse and
the kids don't have it done.
Then it's especially evident.
Oh, you can do that.
You can just circle one face.
You can select one face.
But then one time I saw a family
where I guess in an effort to disguise,
they had done everyone,
including the children.
I was like this fan is a family of angels.
This is great.
Yeah. It's just, I mean,
and then, you know,
I mean, if that's a teenager, boo you
Turn that down.
Talk about...
Brian
Call me immediately, Brian.
I can't take this photo down,
I don't know how to do it.
Oh man, this should have
been the whole episode,
'cause I feel like
we're really getting
into something important.
Yeah, you hadn't even talked
about your damn trip yet.
I've talked about the most important part,
flying there with my dogs.
What about skiing man?
Face filtering the dogs.
I guess we can come back.
Let us know what you
think about face filters.
That's what we do need to
hashtag EarBiscuits about. Okay?
We can do a follow up on this.
We can do an entire expose.
Or maybe we'll just start
applying to face filter to our face.
I finally got to Park City.
The dogs were there.
It was, let me finish the dog part.
I think that it was-
All right.
That's really what I wanted to talk about
the most anyway, apparently.
We were very glad that
we brought the dogs.
We had this like collapsible kennel
that would keep both the dogs that like
I could carry in my suitcase.
So when we left the house,
they didn't just like
potentially pee or poop anywhere.
We also had to pay a fee
at the Airbnb for the dog,
but still, it was not as much as the
keeping 'em in the
kennel, in the pet resort.
Really self-conscious about
saying that I take my
dogs to the pet resort,
but I'm also very proud of it.
So that was a good choice.
On the way back, we
were much more at ease,
knowing the effect that the,
the sedative would have on Jasper,
and like covering the crate.
Like we started to get things down,
to the point where
Christie was talking about,
we're walking in the
airport on the way back,
the dog's heads are sticking
out and people are like,
look pointing and whispering
to other people about
the cuteness of our dogs,
and Christy and I are
looking at each other,
and like, just talking about how,
where are those people
that we've always been
jealous of at the airport?
Really?
Yes,
because they have their dogs
and we don't have our dogs.
And here we are being, we have our dogs.
So is it about the dogs or about you?
Oh, it's definitely about
the dogs are for me.
And again, that, that gets to the,
the emotional support of
the dog clicking into place.
It was like,
Christy experienced it
firsthand with like her
fear of flying.
I was like is having Jasper helping?
You know, petting a dog
releases endorphins.
Yeah,
And then having somebody
that you're caring for-
What about petting a dolphin?
Yeah, emotional support dog.
Ain't nowhere it releases in dolphins.
That's not how baby dolphins are made.
Sorry.
Releasing in dolphins.
I mean, that might work on a t-shirt
but you're in dad joke territory here-.
Should I go tweet that?
No.
Emotional support, no,
'cause you don't wanna tweet about
emotional support stuff and.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
I would, I would find a different way in.
We've dug too much of a
hole of talking about like
women wear makeup today.
Right.
And men.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And all people.
Damn.
whatever.
Okay.
So yeah. I'm like,
I think we've backed into a
legitimate case for Jasper
becoming an emotional support dog.
And then I don't think I
have to pay to $150 each way.
And I don't think I have
to put 'em in a kennel.
But I mean,
she's got a fair fight.
But you had to give him
a little jacket vest.
And that's great. Right?
Yeah. But I, I didn't
wanna be that person.
You can get an emotional support
certification for probably,
and for squirrly reasons,
I've been told.
But I didn't want to do that.
Yeah,
'Cause no one's gonna
like say no all along.
I did not wanna abuse that system,
but now I find that like.
But it might be legitimate.
Christie might be a legitimate
candidate and then it's like,
we might need to
grandfather, me and Jaden.
Question.
It definitely helped her.
And, it helped me too.
Like, I would take Jade
everywhere if I could,
she should be here right now.
But the circumstances of
this trip led themselves to
them not being an inconvenience,
but like, let's just say you decided,
Hey, family to trip to France.
I don't, yeah.
Especially when you don't
have a home base that you're,
that someone is there most of the time,
like everything kind of lined up.
So it's still a trip to trip.
Yeah, yeah, Yeah.
But I was making the argument
when we go back home,
and we stay in an Airbnb,
we can take the dogs to visit our family.
And I think they'll be fine.
So I'm lobbying for that
to be the next thing.
Yeah, yeah.
For Christmas, we're
bringing the dogs home.
Our plan is to take Barbara,
'cause we're going to North
Carolina in the summer,
and we'll be staying
at the place, you know,
the place that we bought there, and,
For maybe longer than a week?
It might be two.
But the plan is to take
Barbara for that trip.
I think Barbara will do fine on the plane.
The only thing that's
gonna be a problem is,
she likes people and food so much that.
She may start whining
The vet, the vet can
give her the sedative,
and they said,
we could give Jasper another one,
if he can needed it.
But other than that, if I
did not have a home base.
No.
It's just such an inconvenience.
And Barbara loves going to the pet resort
is what she tells me
every time she gets back.
I'm sure she does.
You can look on the web camera.
I really bonded with
those bitches this time,
Yeah.
A few of 'em use the face filter.
Yeah, right.
I don't know about those.
I don't know about those ones
with identity issues but,
Okay, the Park City skiing it of it all.
I, you know, I didn't have it.
There's not any like huge thing
I wanted to tell you about,
but how.
Hard did you go? And you
skied instead of snowboarded.
I skied,
we went park city and canyon
resorts are now combined to be
like super large.
I think was the largest
ski resort in the lower 48.
We also went to a third.
Or all resort.
Called deer valley,
which was just like another
seven minute beyond.
We, I, we had never skied deer valley.
I don't think no snowboarders
are allowed there.
The thing about river valley
and park city canyons,
not so much was that if
you wanna ride greens,
I guess I'm not snowboarding.
So I won't say ride ski
greens, which Lincoln.
And I could do some blues,
but we're still getting
our bearing with skiing.
And Lando is not ready for blue lose.
Now, after being there
for three days or before.
Even now, you know,
it's talk about anxiety.
Like the mixture of bringing
anxiety to the slopes is like,
is a big test. And of
course, you know, he,
he deals with anxiety too.
So does Lily and like
Lily learn how to ski,
but then she was like, it
just, it makes me real,
really anxious to like be
going down a mountain on these
like flat wooden things.
You know, it's like species.
And wooden skis.
Well, that's a problem.
Welcome. I guess they're.
Not to the nineties.
They're not wooden.
Okay.
My Popeye had wooden water skis.
That's what I was thinking about.
The ones that are hanging
up on the GM set. Yeah.
But Lando, when we eased him
into it, he did really well.
And it was so it was just
test of anxiety of like, okay,
being in a comfort zone,
you know, if you, so no,
I did not push myself. I made a decision.
It's like, I wanna enjoy
myself in, you know,
I don't wanna hurt myself.
That's the only thing
I'm think about most.
Of the time. It's like the
thing about the greens there,
unlike definitely big bear,
even mammoth is that like,
you got like the lower part
where you got the greens and
then you keep going up the
mountain and it gets like,
it gets more complex and like
black diamond as you go H
higher elevation. Well,
that's not really the case at park city.
There are way you can go
all the way to the top.
And definitely at deer valley,
you can go all the way to the
top and then ski greens all
the way down. So it's like,
you can do these like really long runs.
And I was able to take Lando
all the way up there and really
enjoy it just to like, kinda
take our time, do some,
do some carving. It was warm too.
It was nice. I mean, so
the snow wasn't great,
but we don't care. I it's
like I'll drink any red wine.
You know, I'll ski any
slope, especially if like.
If it's not don't combine those.
If it's not absolutely frigid.
Yeah. I'm not drinking drinking
wine, but on, on the slope.
But we had, so we had a
really good experience.
Le didn't have the endurance or the,
just the appetite to stay
as long as land Lincoln.
And I so like Lincoln and I
could do some more blues when he
wasn't around. There's just
so many places to explore.
And when I, I gotta say,
if you're on skis and you go
to a place that doesn't allow
snowboarders, it that's a,
that's not gonna happen much
longer. It's just economically,
there's no way they're gonna
keep outlying snowboarding at,
at deer valley.
There's too many grandkids that
the grandparents want 'em to
go skiing. If.
They've gotten until 20,
22, without allowing.
Eric was even saying, there's
no way this will continue.
Well, they're holding.
Out, they're holding out big time.
But it,
it is a entirely different
experience because snowboarders
are they're punks. They're punks.
They're, they're teenagers,
low they're 20 somethings.
And they they're knuckled dragon.
And they're like boot and
they're like taking up space and
they got this big blind spot
and they're tearing up the
slopes and like I'm
becoming Hoy toy about it,
but I'll tell you, I mean,
it definitely feels different 'cause
it was a different crowd.
It's an, it's an older crowd.
It's a more docile crowd.
It's a less stinky crowd,
but I will go back to
snowboarding. I was like, Lincoln,
you gotta learn a snowboard too. And I,
I can definitely get back on there. I, I,
I don't know what my pelvis will do.
Yeah. I think I ultimately
had more fun snowboarding,
but I just don't think I can
do it. I, I think that the,
the stress on the back
is just too much. I mean,
that's why I.
Switched. Yeah.
But the stress on the knees.
And I to ligament in my scheme.
So there you go. It's
like, it can still, it,
you can make an argument that
snowboarding is, is safer.
I'd safer.
I'd rather sacrifice the
knees than the back though.
Okay.
See,
I think I got into skiing
because you started scaring me
about that. But like, I
actually don't know if for me,
snowboarding may be a better choice,
but I wanna be able to
go both ways, you know?
Okay.
You hear me?
The air being and be,
we stayed at every morning
when we woke up, I,
it was like this, this,
like all the windows were
like two stories of windows,
like facing the ski slopes
across the valley at night.
I could, I would sit there
at the windows and see,
of course the, the slopes
close at like four o'clock.
But like at midnight you
can see the groomers,
like those big snow cats coming down,
like they got their headlights
on and it looks like falling
stars just like traversing the slopes.
And it was a full moon. It
was a be, it was a beautiful,
beautiful night.
And then the next morning I
get up and in our backyard,
there's a herd of elk grazing. Oh really?
Elk. I herd of freaking.
Elk, never seen an elk in person.
Grazing right there. And they came in elk.
They came back every morning.
The first morning the dogs
were going ballistic. And,
and I was like.
What? There's some, there's.
Some fluffy deer out there.
And Christy's like, I
don't think that's a deer.
Well, I was like, well.
They, they like the size of horses.
Yeah. Cause they're very big.
Oh yeah.
Yeah. And then Christy's
like, I, I was like, well, I,
you know what? I think it's an elk.
She looked it up.
You're enough re it was elk
sitting right out there.
Just grazing, taking little,
little dumps at the edge of
my backyard that then the dogs
would go out there and
investigate afterwards.
And Jasper would probably try to get.
I did not let the dogs out
while the elk were there.
I didn't know what would happen.
Get kicked in the face
or something like that.
I doubt it. They probably would run.
So the final highlight, one
night we Christie booked.
She was like, we're
going to the Viking year.
I was like, what.
A year is like, what is
that like a big tent?
She's like, yeah.
I was like.
She's like,
it's on the top of a mountain
and you're gonna ride in a
Leigh to get there.
So it's like,
we show up and there's this
one of those snow cats,
you know,
that like pulls the stuff
that grooms the mountain,
like with the treads and stuff
that can go straight up the
mountain.
It was pulling this like sled
type thing that would hold 20
people.
And so like all the of us. And what.
City was this in?
This is in park city.
This was in park city.
This is on the park city slope.
Oh, okay.
'Cause they have a thing like this.
Like you go to the resort,
it's a restaurant.
Yeah. It's a restaurant.
So you, so you get on the sleigh,
pulled by the snowcap and
you go up the mountain.
Christie who wasn't skiing the slopes.
We're like telling her, oh,
we were ski in the slope.
We, we were like, we were
here today and just like,
so she gotta experience the slopes,
even though she didn't wanna
ski. And we go up there again,
it was a full moon.
By the time we get up there to
this like tent that will hold
like individual tables
enough for like 20 people.
So pretty small.
And it was six course meal.
I was like, man, I'm not used
to sitting down eating a,
a six course of meal. I'm not
used to eating for two hours.
I'm not French.
Yeah.
It was awesome though.
And we get up there to the top
and it turns out we had skied
all around that thing.
We didn't even notice that
there was a year right there.
Was it a Viking?
It was Viking themed.
We wore Viking helmets for some photo ops.
Yeah. Did.
It's was it like eating with your hands
or was it like mini?
He.
Didn't go that far. No, we
still spoke English and the,
the no one was no one was killed
and no one was making love
in the year in front of everybody.
And nobody there weren't people.
Like, that's what I think about.
Like I watched the show Vikings
and that's that's the thing
I remember is that they
were making love in the,
under the bare skins
in front of everybody.
Right. But were there people like who?
No. Looked like Viking serving and stuff.
No. Did I get.
A job there? No, they were.
They served us some grog,
which was like a spiced.
I don't know.
WASL Okay.
Some sort of a was drink. I would call it,
they call it grog.
They kind of frown when
I said, oh you is this,
this tastes like ale.
Hmm.
And then they spiked it
and we had a good night.
Came back down.
Take the lay down.
Took the sleigh back down. Hold.
On. When you take the lay down there,
is it not being pulled
anymore? It's just, just free.
Fall. It's let you go on
the, on the way up, man.
There were all these
groups of like, like Utah.
He people with skis going up the mountain.
To get to the year.
No, just like, this is what
they do on a Thursday night.
Cross country skiing. Well,
it turns out it's not cross
country. It's uphill skiing.
They were going up the hill. I was like,
how does this happen? I had to ask Eric.
He was like, oh, it's called skiing.
And then he out and he got, he
was like, here are my skins.
It's like, fill of it.
You put your, you put
this skin over your ski.
And then if you rub it one
way, he's like, you know,
those pillows you rub and it's
smooth one way and you rub it
the other way and it's like.
Dark, you push it forward.
It grabs a slope and you can go. Yeah.
It's fabric.
And it's called skin. Maybe.
You gotta make sure put
those on the right way.
My guess is that they would like
put elk skin on there back
in the day.
And if you rub the, the hairs,
if you go against the grain,
you can climb up the mountain.
So there's people like.
Only rubbing elk one way. So.
Uphill Al Alpine touring or skin. And.
They probably disconnect their heel and.
The heel is disconnect.
And then you can, once you
hike up, then you turn around,
you get to the top, you take your,
your skins off and you readjust
your boots and you ski back
down.
I mean, I'm, that seems pretty cool.
It's another thing. So then
you got, yeah, it's a workout.
Like I, I really like park city, man.
I really like it. I, I, I
think I'm gonna be going back.
I mean, in the summertime
there's mountain biking that,
you know,
everything converts to being
still an outdoor play place for
mountain biking. Eric's
definitely trying to talk,
talk me into like getting a
place in park city. I'm like,
well let's not get ahead of ourselves.
On mountain bike.
Yeah.
So I don't know positive
report on park city, man.
I'm glad you didn't get hurt.
I didn't get hurt.
So that's you gotta, you got,
I mean you gotta push
it a little harder. No,
you gotta get a Ralph in your
life that takes you to at the
top of the mountains and just Nope.
Throws you into a blizzard
and then you have to beg the
person to let you go back down
the lifts that turns you into
a man.
Not if you go back down on the lift.
Well, they didn't let me.
If you had to do it again,
would you have gone down the lift?
Well, I, no, I don't have to do it again.
I'm glad I didn't go down the lift if.
Time traveled back to that
moment where you decided to not
go back on the no,
cause it turned you have
gone down the lift. No, it.
Turns out, ended up being fine.
I thought that's when you hurt your.
Knee. No, no.
I hurt my knee on a green. Oh.
Yeah. You can.
Have it doesn't matter.
The, the color of the, the,
the slope doesn't indicate the.
Is it my right today.
Necessarily.
Rec baby rec baby 1, 2, 3, 4.
I'll wrap it up with found
another music podcast.
You know, I'm into classic
hiphop music podcast.
More of them are coming out
of the woodwork. It's like,
it's, it's kind of like the,
the founding fathers of hiphop
are coming into grips with
the fact that like, Hey, we're
still here and we're, we're,
we're holding the,
we're holding the mantle for
what we've built and for,
for what's blown up to what
it is today and strengthening
the ties between early hip hop
and what it's become today.
And so that they can be appreciated.
And in some ways, if still relevant,
I think the perfect example of that,
if you're into what I'm saying
is the bridge 50 years of hip
hop is hosted by NAS and MIS info.
Lots of good episodes that I've enjoyed.
Ice hug, DJ jazzy, Jeff,
Reverend Ron from Ron DMC
listened to Cypress hill.
Recently. These are all
like throwback episodes.
There's some, he also interviews core day.
So he is got some, he's got
some new, but NAS, you know,
he's, he's hip hop legend,
so he can get people to come
on his show that won't do any
other podcasts like Chuck D.
And so it's, if you're
into that, like I am,
it's really cool. And if you're
not, you wouldn't like it.
The bridge, this is Spotify original.
So it's only on Spotify,
I guess, have at it.
And we'll see you next week. Oh, you.
You weren't ready To
watch more ear biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of your biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.